[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts uh
you know a news story coming out
um and this is you know somebody that we
know and you know don't know super well
but we know a little bit
um and it's kind of crazy
um Greta thundberg has been arrested for
human trafficking
um and and this is something that I
think Bears uh you know we have to
mention we have to speak about Greta
thundberg of course is the climate
activist from where is she from Sweden
Switzerland so Scandinavia one of these
places but Greta
um thundberg is one of these people who
we all believe to be an altruist
um you know someone who is uh at their
heart good
and
um she is now being arrested for human
trafficking and rape well I bet human
trafficking in Romania gets a little
slippery yeah I bet that's just like
driving them from one Providence to
another and you're like was she in seat
belt
wait did he abduct somebody
abducting's a little slippery of a slope
it is I guarantee you there's been a
time I can give you a ride yeah yeah and
I was like get in the [ __ ] car we're
going home yeah or I'm guarantee you
she's abducted me a couple times she's
like you're done we're going I think
I've seen those and then legally I got
abducted by her yeah and she probably
drove me into another state human
trafficking uh the ray was part of the
the American was being held captive at
the house okay I mean you know these are
also reports yeah these are just reports
I mean I think look the guys this is
gonna come by the way I'm sure all this
will come out in the wash once this is
airing because this is we're reading
this as today yeah but uh I bet this is
all gonna be fine for him if he doesn't
go away for something that people view
as morally reprehensible I think it only
increases his star power oh yeah and the
fervor of his fan base he's already
bigger now 100 yeah be and especially
like let's say he does five years for
tax evasion it's like oh they couldn't
stop him so they had to get him on tax
evasion oh he was too powerful The
Matrix was trying to quiet him it's like
or maybe he was Finding ways to skirt
around taxes and he wasn't you know
bribing the right people in Romania
that's the other thing it's like my man
was talking about how corrupted
it's like if your homies if you are
paying [ __ ] off say Romania is
not corrupt at all it's the perfect
place and you want people to move there
it's amazing and you're almost existing
Romania to prosecute you even if it is a
corrupt place you can't go say that [ __ ]
to millions of people you're basically
going you won't yeah do it you're saying
do it okay they did it Romania I don't
know what their system is like I don't
know whether they're corrupt I've heard
things but I don't know I don't have any
real information so I'd be talking out
of my ass to say
you know if he really did like sex
traffic people if he really did all the
things he's saying well I hope that gets
proven in court and I I hope he gets
punished if he really did that if he
didn't do that I hope he gets exonerated
and I hope he gets the [ __ ] out of
Romania I don't know I don't know what
he did I know a lot of what he does is
theater right a lot of what he does is
very like satire he he plays the role of
this boastful misogynist who smokes
cigars and drives Lamborghinis and
that's his thing and because of that
he's amassed an amazing amount of money
and he's done it by doing this
character's online persona but then also
says very wise things he says ridiculous
[ __ ] but also says really interesting
things he's a very smart guy if you live
listen to him being interviewed by
Patrick Bet David for a long-form
conversation they talk for hours and you
get to see this is a very intelligent
and calculated guy you might not agree
with his message you might not agree
with all the misogynist stuff you might
not agree with and I don't agree with it
you might not agree with all the the
crazy Antics but you cannot deny that
that's been incredibly successful
because it resonates with a lot of young
men who don't feel represented in the
media and they see this guy and it looks
like fun do they agree with what he's
saying that doesn't mean they agree with
it they think it's fun it's like pro
wrestling he's like a bad guy in pro
wrestling he's a heel Tate has angered
some very high profile people and he's
been a controversial figure and I'm sure
that people in Romania are not happy
with that I'm sure that the heat he's
bringing on Romania is not something
they like and I'm sure there's a culture
in Romania of crime that he
um by just existing and by Romania
getting more attention now than it's
ever had uh there's a culture of quiet
corruption that they would like to keep
quiet and when he's on his show talking
about oh this is how it works you pay
people off you pay off officials you do
this you do that
um
I'm sure that there's people there that
do not like him and you know I'm not
intimately familiar with these charges
he's tweeting right now God is on our
side so the Matrix will not win in
shalah he's a Muslim now
here's the thing he knows what he's
doing that the funny thing oh yeah is
the people who are like this they think
this is just a wild man let loose and
you're like this guy is very calculated
very and he's he is intelligent he's not
just I think he's very young like he
comes with a reason it's entertainment
but I do think I know he got arrested
for human trafficking but I don't know
what the details are yeah and I don't
know sometimes you can get caught up
like it's like it's like male fraud
you're like oh come on yeah I was
mailing him a bag of [ __ ] what do you
mean so I don't know if those charges
were dropped he got kicked off Instagram
like what he got kicked off Instagram
Instagram and
and it's all going wrong for I okay how
here how can mainstream media not love
this guy here's what I understand about
mainstream media he is creating content
for you in a world where you all you
want is content to be doing the things
he's being accused of doing and then go
seek publicity
is a very unwise move if he's did the
thing correct he did then then it's like
what you would think if you're
committing atrocities you would try to
stay under the radar he does quite the
opposite yeah but but again we don't
know no nobody knows that's the problem
is I mean that's like a pizza thing the
pizza box I don't know if you saw that
everybody saying he got busted because
of the pizza box and then the author is
like that nothing to do with no they
knew he was in Romania it was just
what's that word schadenfrod shot and
fruit shot and fruit that's been what it
was like he's making fun of Greta
thornberg and then he gets [ __ ]
arrested right afterwards it's kind of
hilarious yeah the way it happens is
like people said it's the biggest like
self self third biggest tweet or retweet
it was Greta I mean it was yeah it was
okay it's kind of funny when she said
that's what happens you don't recycle it
was yeah yeah that was good Chad that
shit's hilarious you got to give it to
her this is big yeah they said I thought
I'd rather Thunder put him in jail
that's what everybody thought because
the timing was dubious that's what I
believed because he was talking that
[ __ ] to Greta and then they said that
they used the pizza boxes yeah in his
retaliation video to prove that he was
in town and then they arrested him
apparently that's [ __ ] yeah
apparently that's not true okay which is
one of those things that when you hear
about it first you're like whoa that's
so crazy and then after you think about
it would have been so funny yeah there's
no way they're like watching his dreams
like we got him yeah like they just
couldn't see his passport like when he
got in the country and they're like yeah
he's here or just drive up to the castle
and see if he's there yeah right you
just knock on the door and be like hey
is Andrew here yeah there's got to be
other ways for the government to know if
you're in the country other than like
you ordering like pepperoni pizzas 100
and the mother of all coincidences
in addition to Greta Sundberg Andrew
Tate has been arrested in Romania and
he's being detained for 30 days
I went to Romania I went to Bucharest to
do a gig for a Bitcoin guy who had paid
me a good sum of money to perform at his
birthday party many of the people at the
party uh did not speak English it made a
difficult crowd for a comedian
um but the check cleared they were uh
hospitable to me but I had to spend you
know two or three days in Bucharest
Romania and the only person to interview
in Bucharest Romania was Andrew Tate who
was a lovely man to me and my producer
he was a delightful character this is
true I love anyone that shows up in a
Rolls-Royce who puts me in a Rolls-Royce
I mean you know and some of the women
with him I don't know what was going on
they seemed quiet and I thought they
were just quiet
you know it would which is a little you
know to be honest coming from America
it's a nice change of pace that the
women were a little quiet that they were
more reserved we went to a steakhouse we
had a great meal with uh Andrew and
Tristan there was no evidence
of human trafficking besides you know
the women who were a little quiet and
kind of looked at the floor and didn't
speak
um
but again it's eastern Europe so I think
that's cultural how can you believe
anything that is said about somebody so
controversial because everybody
seemingly has already made up their mind
right so where to get real information
on him who knows all the objectionable
stuff I think also was unnecessary I
think if he want I mean I don't know him
if I did know him I would tell him all
the the boastful [ __ ] and the the [ __ ]
about him being you know the top G and
all that stuff all that shit's great but
the misogynistic stuff like if you have
daughters or if you have a wife or if
you have sisters and stuff like that you
don't want that well you know that that
that narrative like putting that out
there that's negative to everybody it's
not it's not even positive to him it's
like it's not necessary you already know
that there's an investigation going on
in you obviously if he's as big as he is
if he's the top G in Romania he has
people in the probably the police
department or their version of the FBI
or whatever the [ __ ] it is or like yo
there's an ongoing investigation about
you you know they're eventually going to
go back in jail so of course go on all
these platforms and then say the Matrix
is coming for me is it the Matrix or is
it the [ __ ] police that have
said hey we're building this case
against you you know what else to that
point I was when I was looking like Tori
going listen The Matrix is after me I
mean I know I shot this woman in the
foot but the Matrix is conspiring to put
me in prison he's an alpha
I don't know anything about him but I
don't like it because I feel like he
would have liked what you just said
what's less Alpha than paying to learn
to be an alpha
that should be the whole seminar you can
show up he's like who paid and they all
raise your hand he's like get the [ __ ]
out
one guy's in there giving him the finger
he's like this is my protege
so Andrew Tate is in prison for 30 days
yes on what
not sex trafficking that's what everyone
thought at first they thought it was sex
trafficking organized crime allegations
correct connection to what the mafia
yeah is that it organized crime so yeah
I guess you would go to believe Mafia
okay but there's a few allegations
they've been investigating since his
last arrest in April allegedly he one of
his women that was making like 50 000 55
000 a month on the cams that he was
forced to work said she didn't make a
dollar off of it so that's sex slavery I
assume she wasn't a top earner fit the
measly 55 a month bro that's the 700k a
year come on okay
the people that support him no matter
what are going to support him no matter
what they're not really going to Care
300 women came out and say we were Cosby
drugged and raped
um
people that support him are gonna go
their agents of the Matrix they're Liars
it doesn't matter and the people that
hate him and the things he says are
going to believe he is a rapist no
matter what even if it is not proven
even if some of these victims uh their
credibility is called into question
everybody talking about this guy I don't
care what should I know about this guy
is he good or bad
oh you enjoyed you like him
no oh okay I thought women handed him oh
you gotta get your [ __ ] she's fun
lady she does anal
she knows all right
[Applause]
nailed it I want to smell that guy's
hand I can't tell if his brother is a
real person
oh really I think it's him split screams
I think he's smart enough to do split
screen he is smart by the way oh I've
just figured out what I'm doing what uh
I'm doing Bert Kreischer split screens
I'm gonna do split screens with me and
my twin brother Brent
crystals and Bert Chrysler and Brent's
Crystal's gonna be a [ __ ] lunatic oh
what's work gonna be like
it's a reason oh yeah I think I should
flip a nice shower I think Brent should
be the voice of reason they were lovely
to me that's all I can say I would they
did not traffic me they trafficked me in
a Rolls-Royce
so I mean
I you can traffic me and you know I mean
the women at the house were lovely they
were quiet and they didn't look me in
the eye and you know because that's so I
and I thought and I and I still withhold
judgment the house the decor of the
house was
a little human trafficker if I had to if
I had to Peg the decor
if they brought in a designer and uh
gave the designer inspiration it would
be
and sex trafficking
I mean it's all black it's kind of sexy
there's like secret rooms and
everybody's on closed circuit TV
you know
but I don't know is that human
trafficking per se that you have a sexy
house with secret Panic rooms and then
everybody's on close circuit TV all the
time
I don't know I don't know Epstein had
that a little bit right but that's maybe
part of the package I don't know I love
real estate and I love homes and I
respect different people in there and
the way that they choose to live so some
people are going to want more of like
let's say French Colonial some people
want a traditional Spanish some people
are going to want to Modern and some
people are going to want um an Eastern
European Sex Dungeon
foreign
[Music]